6-Nuit English
From BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-minute English from BBC Learning English, I'm Neil
And I'm Beth
We all know how horrible it feels to be thirsty
Human bodies need around 3 litres of water a day
And thankfully most of us can just turn on the kitchen tap to get clean drinking water
But globally over 2 billion people around a quarter of the world's population live in water
stressed countries where access to water for drinking, cooking and washing is not guaranteed
What's more, water is also needed to grow food and that's getting harder due to droughts
which are increasing with climate change
In this programme we'll visit farmers in one of the driest places on earth, Yuma in the USA
where a new technology involving liquid clay is helping farmers grow fruit and vegetables in the desert
And as usual we'll be learning some useful new vocabulary too
But first I have a question for you Neil
Everyone knows that plants need sunlight and water to grow
but soil is just as important
One of the most useful soils is clay, a dense, smooth soil which is very fertile but sticky
Clay has been used in agriculture for thousands of years
But what is its more modern use?
Is clay good for a. Curing headaches, b. Digesting food or c.
Smoothing face skin
Well I think clay can be used to smooth the skin on people's faces
Okay Neil, we'll find out if that's the correct answer later
Lack of water and farming are closely connected
Agriculture uses a massive 70% of the world's fresh water supply
so ways to use water more efficiently are much needed
Oles-Sivitzen's company Desert Control works with date farmers in Yuma
an area on the border of California and Mexico
One of the hottest places on earth, Yuma has been experiencing its worst drought in 500 years
forcing farmers to pump water from rivers to grow their date palm trees
Fortunately, Oles team have created a liquid that they say
can turn the sandy desert soil into a sponge which holds water and nutrients
Here he explains his invention to Anthony Wallace
reporter for BBC World Service program People Fixing the World
To understand how it works we need to look at the difference between sandy soil and clay soil
sandy desert soil has a lot of gaps in it
so water drains through it quickly making it harder for plants to establish a root system in the ground
but clay soil is made up of much smaller particles that cling together and naturally stop water from escaping
It creates the habitat for the soil microbiology to also start to develop and evolve
so it's kind of a kickstart as well to nature's natural processes
The problem with sandy soil is that it drains water
if you drain something you remove the liquid from it
Clay soil on the other hand is made of smaller particles which cling or stick together tightly
and hold water helping plants grow
Oles makes a liquid by mixing clay and water which changes the soil composition
and kick starts the growth of his trees
the liquid makes the trees start growing more quickly
liquid clay technology is still new and costing around $2,000 an acre
it's not cheap but Oles claims his technique halves the amount of water needed to grow fruit trees
and that most farmers will make back their investment within two years
Oles claims sound too good to be true but are there downsides to interfering with nature in this way
presenters Myra and Nubi and Anthony Wallace discuss this question for BBC World Services
People Fixing the World
Anthony I'm still left wondering right when you manipulate soil like this
Could you be causing problems down the line?
Yeah I think anytime that there's a new technology where you are like you said
manipulating nature only time will tell what the long term effects of that will be
but Oles did stress that their liquid clay does not use any chemicals only clay, air and water
Oles liquid clay involves manipulating soil using and controlling it skillfully to achieve some results
Myra worries that when people do this they could create problems down the line at some unspecified point in the future
In fact only time will tell if liquid clay is a long term solution to the problem of water scarcity
the phrase only time will tell means that the result of something happening now will not be known
until the future something we can know though is the answer to my question Neil
Yes you asked about a modern use for clay and I guessed it was for smoothing facial skin
Which was the correct answer a clay mask also called a mud pack is used to smooth the skin on your face
Okay let's recap the vocabulary we've learnt in this programme starting with the verb to drain
which means to remove liquid to cling it means to stick or hold tightly onto something
if you kick start something you make it start or develop more quickly
to manipulate means to skillfully use or control something
the phrase down the line means sometime in the future
and finally the idiom only time will tell means that the truth about something happening now will
only be known in the future once again our six minutes are up but remember to join us again
next time for more trending topics and useful vocabulary here at six minute English goodbye for now
bye
six minute English from bbclearningenglish.com